okay today I'm going to talk to you
about filtration and crystallization so
these are two different processes we're
going to see the equipment that we need
for each when we'd use each technique
and how they operate so let's start with
filtration so filtration is when you
want to separate an insoluble solid from
a liquid so what insoluble means means
it does not dissolve so let's have a
look at an example so here I have a
beaker and in that beaker I have a
mixture of sand and water
so my sand is my in soluble solid
because sand does not dissolve in water
so to be able to separate the water from
the sand I'm going to use filtration
which is a really simple process all
that I need is a beaker a funnel and in
the funnel goes some filter paper so
filter paper has these tiny little pores
and that allows certain things to flow
through but larger insoluble things it
does not allow to flow through so all
you need to do is get your mixture of
your insoluble solid and liquid and you
put it through there now all of the
insoluble solid is going to stay in the
filter paper because it's too big to fit
through whereas the liquid will drip
through and collect at the bottom so
you've beautifully managed to separate
the insoluble solid from the liquid now
this only works for in soluble solids if
we have a soluble stuff solid we have to
use a different process called
crystallization crystallization yeah so
if let's say this was salty water
and sand the salty water because the
salt is dissolved in the water it would
go straight through the filter paper
because it's broken up and dissolved in
solution so instead we need to do a
process called crystallization so
crystallization is how you separate a
soluble solid from a solution so a
really common example that we could look
at would just be if I had a beaker
containing salty water so sodium
chloride dissolved in water salty water
my salt is my substance which is soluble
meaning it dissolves right so this time
instead of using a funnel what you need
to do is you need to use the following
equipment so right here I have my Bunsen
burner that's what's going to provide
the heat because we need to evaporate
that water here we just have a tripod
and on the tripod will have a gauze and
on there we have an evaporating dish you
may also have heard this being called an
evaporating basin before as well so what
you need to do is you need to get that
salty water or whatever your soluble
solid is you need to get that and you
put it into your evaporating Basin and
you start to heat it what will happen is
the water will evaporate and it will
leave crystals of our salt behind that's
why it's called crystallization because
lit behind will be left loads of salt
crystals so finally once we've done that
if you want to dry it even further you
could use a bit of equipment called a
desiccator which is specially designed
to remove even more of the water to
leave us some nice crystals of salt now
we've separated it
so quick recap filtration is used to
separate an insoluble solid from liquid
all you need to do is put it through a
filter paper in a funnel the insoluble
solid that gets left behind and the
liquid goes through the crystallization
is to separate a soluble solid from a
solution that means it can dissolve all
you need to do is put it in a vaporators
dish heat it up the water evaporates and
leaves crystals of your substance behind
for further drying you put it in a
desiccator thank you for listening